the outside may be gray and drab but
inside the colorful world of football
comes to the fore the museum has spread
over three floors of a former Bank in
downtown Zurich for triode founder and
exhibition designer Lutz Engel curve the
challenge was to convey the powerful
emotions linked to football within the
rigid walls of a static museum through
media as you saw downstairs in the foyer
we have an almost 240 degree wall of
screens on the one side then we've
frozen football in time with individual
objects the museum is a mix of
acceleration and deceleration at the
center of the museum is a rainbow of
football jerseys from all 209 member
associations of FIFA complete with video
content for each shirt
the original FIFA World Cup trophy
stands in pride of place the new museum
accentuates the positive firstly we want
people to have fun secondly we want them
to realize that FIFA is about more than
the scandal of recent years all this has
grown up over 50 60 70 years without the
FIFA rules world football wouldn't exist
and we want to show how a ball can
promote understanding between people
FIFA hopes the new museum will help keep
that ball rolling berlin-based riad has
created a modern museum space that
celebrates the emotion of the beautiful
game
you